[Music]
my name is Seth Wiesman I'm a Solutions
Architect with verve Erica so yeah we
are the original the company founded by
the original creators of Apache flink
you may also know us as data artisans we
rebranded at the beginning of this year
but we are the same organization so
along with supporting the open-source
community we also offer some enterprise
tools so on flink as its name implies as
a top-level Apache project and we're all
about doing stateful computations over
data streams so it's a fairly large
framework contains a number of features
but the thing I really want to focus on
for this talk is stateful our goal is
that you're writing really simple code
the kind of stuff you're doing back in
your cs101 course where you're just
using local variables and do what seem
simple and we're gonna make it stateful
fault-tolerant scalable all those good
things out of the box these are some of
the logos from our powered by page Flinx
widely deployed across industry
companies large and small and we are
proving out at scale so these numbers
come from Alibaba on singles day which
is the largest online shopping day in
the world and everything in Alibaba is
powered by Flinx so we were running on
clusters with tens of thousands of nodes
doing billions of events per second with
sub-second latency and managing hundreds
of terabytes of state within the flink
applications themselves with the
confidence that plink was providing
correct reliable results now singles day
this year was actually just this past
Monday these numbers are from 2018 I
don't have the 2019 numbers yet but
Alibaba increased its one-day revenue by
8 billion dollars so I expect that these
numbers are comparable larger but I
actually don't want to talk about stream
processing at least not quite yet
instead I'd like to focus on application
developments so the set of logos comes
from just a cursory search I did of the
Apache Frank mailing list looking for
phrases like I'm running the stream
processing job and also spring boot or
rails or whatever it might be and we see
a really wide variety of logos but
that makes sense because stream
provocation development is a very broad
category however there's one sub
category of frameworks we've seen a lot
of growth in over the past year so and
that is serverless or functions as a
service now I realize these are not
strictly the same thing however I'm
willingly speaking on them at a very
high level so please don't get too mad
if I use these terms interchangeably and
what is this category at its core well
function as a service as its name
implies is all about building
event-driven functions and I think
that's a really interesting place to
start thinking about where stream
processing and application development
might come together because they both
share this very particular
characteristic of being reactive to
events and while event-driven is not
stream processing by any means I think
it's a very fine line between reacting
to a single events and reacting to a
stream of events and one of the most
interesting properties of these systems
brings to the table is their elastic
scalability so as load increases a
useful function as a service will
automatically scale up and spawn more
instances so it can handle that load and
when they're no longer needed those
instances will go back down this means
it has what I'm going to call a very
lightweight resource footprint it only
uses what's necessary at any given
moment to solve the problem and no more
well that sounds really good there's
also a reason why this hasn't quite
taken over the world yet and that's
because most real systems need to do
more than simply invoke a single
function or do processing based on the
information encoded within a single
event most real systems are safe full
and once we pull in some data store a
second tier our story is going to start
to fall apart a little bit we need to
start considering things like state
consistency so what happens when I have
multiple functions interacting with the
database in random ways when things seem
slow it's very rarely the compute inside
the function itself that's our
bottleneck more often than not it is the
interaction between these two layers
we're spending most of our time simply
waiting on IO to
it's when we really do want to scale the
system right the compute layer is very
simple but the data layer less so modern
cloud providers have done a really good
job at trying to hide the complexities
of scaling data stores but at the end of
the day it's still a tough problem and
once you reach a certain scale either in
terms of data volume or frequency and
rescaling the system those details are
going to leak through and you is the
application developer need to deal with
it and this just isn't a smooth
experience anymore when we start
considering things like connection
pooling or how we handle rate limiting
across systems and so on while these
frameworks have made a good start
they're just not ready for building
complex stateful applications but of
course none of this is news right all
you need to do is spend a little too
much time on Twitter to see that these
are real problems that people are facing
in production today another somewhat
related issue is what happens when we
need to do more than simply invoke a
single function write your business is
made up of a mesh of services that need
to communicate with each other in rather
arbitrary ways and we're still missing
composition primitives except in the
very particular case of a workflow
generally speaking you still need to
pull in some extra component a message
queue or event bus that needs to be
managed use properly to get the correct
reliable results that your users expect
so what we're looking for is something
that is event-driven
has strong composability characteristics
and shown that state management can be
easy well to me that sounds a lot like
stream processing and certainly that is
the apache flink view of the world so we
see streaming as a spectrum made up of a
whole host of use cases everything from
really laggy bounded streams or batch
processing all the way to event-driven
applications and even transactional
systems but of course you have very
different needs depending where on the
spectrum you're working that's why Flint
comes with a number of first-class api's
so on the one hand is Flinx equal in the
table api we are an SI sequel compliant
the 2016 standard and unified over both
batch and streaming we support the fold
TPC des query set which is a fancy
way of saying we support most of the
ANSI spec and you know you can write
create table statements and go to our
CLI and write things very quickly
without you know any Java or Scala code
but maybe you need a little more
low-level control right I want to see
each record store value and state set a
callback make an RPC call so on and for
that there's the data stream API and
people have built some really impressive
things on top of data stream but once we
move squarely into this event-driven
space and transactional applications
even this can feel a little too
restrictive and that's why the Flint
community has recently introduced a
brand-new first class API called
stateful functions so very excitingly
between the time that I submitted my
front slides last Friday and now this
disclaimer is no longer relevant so
central functions is no longer a
standalone project it has been voted on
and accepted by the Flint community and
is going to be in the main Apache flink
repo and an official first-class API in
an upcoming release that said this last
point is to relevance it's still a
fairly new API it's fast-moving if you
think what I'm talking about today is
interesting it's a great time to get
involved one caveat the code still is in
that repo however now at least for the
time being so this diagram gives us a
high-level overview of building a
stateful function application and if the
core are the namesake stateful functions
think of these as the building blocks
for your service they can message each
other in really arbitrary ways so this
is one way in which we're moving away
from the traditional stream processing
view of the world instead of simply
saying we're not building up a dataflow
dag anymore but saying that your
functions can message each other in a
distributed arbitrary potentially cyclic
even round-trip way that said I also
want to be clear that we are not looking
to be the next request response
framework here rather we are still very
much in the event-driven space so I'll
walk you through some of the main
features since we're event-driven we
should start with events
and so event ingresses or how we get
data into the system this can be
anything from a Kafka topic to a message
queue to an HTTP server just any way of
getting data into the system that is
then going to trigger the initial
functions to begin computation if the
core as I mentioned are are stateful
functions and so this is where you build
up your business logic they are
distributed across the flink runtime and
can communicate in arbitrary ways if
you're familiar with actor programming
let's does share some similarities
however there are a few very significant
differences the first is that all
functions have locally embedded state
and so this is the thing that Apache
flink does really well you are always
win inside a function when it's
performing some computation you are
always working with local state in local
variables no network the next is that
for both state and messaging we are
still able to provide the exactly once
guarantees you expect out of a modern
stream processor so in the case of
failure we can roll the whole state of
the world both state and messages back
in a consistent manner such to simulate
completely fill your free execution and
the whole thing is no database required
so if you've used flink in the past this
is very much our way of doing things
I'm not simply saying that we've built
this new API and it's really hiding that
old architecture I described a few
slides ago but you're really truly
working with local state that is thread
local and we're managing the fault
tolerance through Flinx proven
distributed asynchronous snapshots
finally if you got to get data out of
course these functions can do whatever
they like make an RPC call and so on but
if you'd like a way of communicating
with the outside world that is tied into
our fault tolerance for that we supply
event aggresses now the other really key
way in which this is different from an
actor system is this concept of logical
or virtual instances so imagine we have
two shards these would be tasks slots
inside a flank
I'm not simply saying that we are
allocating a bunch of functions a bunch
of objects across these two chars and
they're gonna start messaging
messaging each other that's a very
simple model to reason about but it's
not very efficient what I want you to do
is instead model every entity has a
function so we're a function will only
consume memory if it is being used if it
is not actively being invoked it will
consume no memory use no threads have no
resource footprint at all instead of
having say one function to model
inventory inside of a business have a
function for every item in an inventory
model every single customer in your
system as its own individual function
that you can message when you want to
update its states so let's look at an
example let's say that we have a number
of functions in C wants to message kay
kay may or may not be actively used in
memory at that moment we will
transparently load it into memory
potentially evicting another I apologize
there's a little animation from
PowerPoint that didn't translate over
potentially evicting D in this case and
then we will go ahead and invoke K as if
it were always available from your point
of view as a user it is as if you have
an infinite number of functions always
available in memory ready to use when
you go to message a function you're
always sending it to an address where
that address is made up of some function
type and an identifier think of your
function type is being very similar to a
class in an object-oriented language
right what sort of function do you want
to message where the ID is the
particular instance and because
everything is logical here there's no
service discovery required you can
simply message a function and your
record is guaranteed to get to the right
place so let's say we have a very simple
hello world example right we have we
want to greet users but specifically we
want to do it based on how many times
they've been seen so far so you might
say hello and then welcome back and then
third time's the charm things like that
and what that means is we need to keep
track of the number of times each user
has been seen by the system so far
also known as states so we might create
a greeter function type right and have
one instance for every single user that
interacts with our system so this would
be our router and this is the thing that
we're going to attach to our ingress and
say for each record how do you send it
to that initial function to begin
computation so we'll get each record and
we will create an address based on the
greeter function type so this is the
sort of function I want to go to and our
user ID this particular one and then for
that message on and we could send this
to any number of functions once we are
inside the function itself we can do
pretty much anything we like so perform
some local computation work with our
state's maybe message any number of
other functions send something to a
[ __ ] write output it's the outside
world even some more complex things like
send a message with a delay that might
be a timer a callback even make an
asynchronous request in a way that it is
registered with the framework so it
happens
tied into our fault tolerance and so
here's our greeter and while this isn't
a lot of code it's actually doing some
very interesting things the first of
which is defining our function type
right so this is the way that we
reference it when we want to message
this function the reason that we do it
this way is defining this function type
object with a string based name as
opposed to referencing the Java class
itself is because these applications are
built up of bundles of functions known
as modules right and any function can
message any other even across modules so
say we have multiple teams developing in
parallel they're writing their own code
and they are only ever going to be
deployed together at runtime by doing it
this way you can define an interface and
say hey I have this function that you're
allowed to message in this way but you
don't have to see the code right I don't
have to know at runs
and what is backing that function even
more interestingly let's say we had a
machine learning use case right so we
have our data engineering team that is
building up feature vectors and they
like doing that in Java but then the
data science team wants to build a model
to score that in production well they
probably want to do that in Python so we
can write two different modules in
different languages and because we've
defined our function type in this way we
can message across the language barrier
transparently you just message the data
science teams function the fact that
it's Python makes no difference to you
next thing we can do is have a persisted
value and so this is our local state we
can have any number of these within a
given function and it is always scoped
to the current address right the
function type and ID so in this case we
are counting the number of times each
user has been seen individually right
every single user has their own count
and then we'll go inside of invoke write
so this is a message comes in we call it
what are we going to do well I can plot
some metadata so I want to get the user
ID right where am I being invoked at
this moments and then do something so
I'm interacting with my local state I'm
reading the value I'm manipulating it
I'm setting it again there is absolutely
no network i/o happening behind the
scenes here we are working with really
truly local data and then do whatever
you like so in this case our big
impressive computation is printing out a
string based on the current counts and
then we can forward that to another
function maybe do some further
processing or send it to an egress and
that's what I'm doing in this case I
want to write it out so I can quickly
greet my user under the hood these are
always logical instances per ID so even
if you have a billion users if my
greeter application gets insanely
popular that does not mean I need to
make a billion allocations on the JVM
heap we very aggressively share objects
and in fact this framework makes very
few allocations after initial setup
these objects are created transparently
so as a application developer you don't
need to be concerned with the lifecycle
the first time that you message a user
right I see user B for the very first
time ever I don't have to care that it's
the first time I will just message their
function and it will be as if it has
always existed we are running on top of
the Apache flink runtime and so we're
taking advantage of being massively
horizontally parallel we get to do
things asynchronously and so on but
we're abstract all that away so from
your perspective everything is single
threaded you don't need to worry about
concurrency primitives and locking and
synchronization and all those tricky
things and finally our messages are very
well ordered so even though we're doing
this in parallel even though we're doing
things asynchronously
if message a sends a message to function
B in fact it sends three messages those
are guaranteed to be processed by
message B in that order even in the case
of failure the ordering is very strict
so let's try and relate this back to
some more traditional streaming concepts
what might our dataflow look like at
least conceptually well it might be
something like this right if we tried to
build out a dag we'd have some sources
right these are ingress --is and we're
sending data to functions and the big
change here is that we are now sending
data horizontally right any function can
message back and forth across the middle
piece of this data flow until finally it
has an output that goes to an egress and
we write it out these would be our sinks
traditionally inflict what we're
actually doing under the hood is
leveraging one of Flinx most powerful
features and that is iteration so the
Apache flink runtime has for a long time
supported iteration or feedback loops in
its data flows this means records do not
have to flow in one direction we can
always have a right back to send data
backups
beginning of our stream and be processed
again and we can do this with exactly
one semantics so functionally what we're
doing here is building an interpreter on
top of the runtime that can run your
functions if we take a little peek under
the hood we have what's called our
function dispatch operator this is our
interpreter
it's the midpoints in this graph and so
what happens is records come in that
could be come from an even ingress for
say and they've been routed somewhere
and so they have an address and then
what happens well we go we get the Java
object on the heap that is associated
with this function type in each
individual dispatcher there is never
more than one Java object allocated per
function type so we might get our
greeter function and then we'll load our
state from Flint State backends this is
where we store state during execution
time again always thread-local always on
the machine will invoke that function
will store any state updates that you
make and then the results of this you
know if you output something that is
being sent to another function what
happens it gets looped back around it
goes through our iteration potentially
landing on a function dispatch operator
on a different node right depending on
our key because we're very distributed
or you wrote something to an egress so
it goes forward out of the dag
the result of okay so just to repeat it
for the camera
what is the results of a function right
it can be one of three things it could
be nothing right I could have made an
RPC call that was a black box to the
system it could be one or more I can
output any number of things messages
that I want to send to other functions
so it is not I'm not outputting a
function I am calling other functions in
my system and I'm gonna show a more
complicated example on the next slide
but you know my greeter function could
then call my I don't know my foo
function I don't have a good example and
I'm going to say here's my function type
here's the ID the instance of my food
that I want to invoke and what happens
we're going to take that record we're
gonna tag it with that meta information
we are then going to loop it back around
so it's gonna go through our function
dispatch again based on the ID the
particular function dispatch that we
send it to might be on a different
physical machine because we are charting
all this but that's transparent and then
we'll invoke it and loop back around and
do it again right it's just a big
interpreter the third option is that I
write it to an egress so a Kafka topic a
database an issue piece what you know
I'm actually out put in the state it's
the outside world in which case it goes
downstream it does not look
just
yes so there is a there's an envelope
that says function type please go here
ID I want this instance and payload in
fact if you look at the code it is
called envelope yeah of course
so of course greeting is not a very
interesting example no one is building
their business on top of saying hello
however people are building businesses
around ride-sharing apps and what we
would like to do is build the core of a
ride-sharing system so this is the thing
that actually links writers to drivers
when you go on in a request to ride oh
you know how does that happen well we
can do this as a stateful function
application so we're gonna have a bunch
of different function types we're gonna
have one for drivers one for passengers
ongoing rides even a Geo index because I
want to link riders with drivers who are
physically close to each other and for
all this we're gonna have many many
entities right I'm gonna have an
instance of driver for every driver that
uses my system in instance a passenger
for every passenger that has my app and
so on now this is not and as you can see
right they message each other in really
complex way so passenger messages ride
that then responds back they all talk to
the Geo index they all do these
interesting things now I'm going to try
and slide a screen over and we're gonna
see if I can do this properly
okay so this is not a theoretical use
case we actually went ahead and
implemented this I have this nice little
UI visualization so you can see the
different entity is moving around the
app hand goes up request a ride driver
comes to them they ride to the
destination ride ends the full source
code for this is in the github
repository please go check it out and
while I wouldn't say that this is a
trivial example by any means right
there's a lot of edge cases and you know
if then else so on I it is rather simple
when you look at the code we did this
all in about 300 lines of user code
because at no point do we need to
consider things like fault tolerance or
consistency or how we message these
other systems all we're doing here is
writing our business logic the system is
making it work we can also go into the
flink UI and see the data flow that is
running this under the hood try and
scroll up a little bit and what you can
see is that even though we're running
this very complex system right there's a
lot of different functions that are
communicating with each other in
arbitrary ways it translates down into
this one data flow and regardless of
what you implement this is always what
flink is going to see all the real
processing happens in our function
dispatcher so this is our interpreter
and if I go back if I can do this
properly we have our feedback and so
what happens data goes from our dispatch
operator to our feedback loop and then
the UI doesn't draw it but it is looping
back around and going to our dispatcher
again so let me
pull this out of the way okay so I will
try to wrap up so where does this fit in
the larger landscape am i saying that
traditional stream processing is going
away absolutely not what I am saying is
that for more state centric applications
stateful functions gives you a better
way of building them so think about
things where you're doing lots of
coordination that ride-sharing app is
essentially a large distributed
consistent state machine but there's
still a good use case for more
traditional stream processing the kinds
of things you're doing with sequel today
the kinds of things you're using the
data stream API more event or stream
centric applications data comes in we're
doing some preparation some ETL some
filtering some aggregations and joints
even function as a service still has a
good place for the occasional spiky
stateless computation so how might these
things go back tie into each other
looking at our ride-sharing application
again we have these different data
streams that are coming in we might do
some forecasting and modeling using the
data stream API and in fact this is how
lyft does all of their real-time pricing
and weather forecasting is on top of
linked data stream but then I need to go
and actually run my app right I need to
set up rides and connect writers and
drivers and for that we'll have a
stateful function application finally I
need to go and print receipts write
write ends I need to take some metadata
and render it as a PDF that's still a
really good use case for a traditional
function as a service so as I mentioned
the code is currently in this repository
but it is actively about to be moved to
the Apache flink repository
there's also full documentation on our
website we even have a Twitter handle if
you'd like to reach out and ask some
questions I think we have a little time
for questions right now I know my office
hours are actually after lunch but I'll
be happy to answer any during lunch as
well thank you
[Applause]
hi so I had a question on sort of like
the concept of maybe like triggers on
the state so suppose like in your taxi
example you do not want to send a
message unless you have three people who
like signed up or within a certain time
frame so how does that sort of concept
sure so let me hold it wait okay so in
this case we will have a ride function
right and that keeps track of all
ongoing rides that might be and we might
have a state that is like setting up the
ride and so what happens as riders get
added right well keep track how many
riders are currently a part of this and
we support sending messages with delay
which is really just a blink timer under
the hood so I could have a timeout
callback that says if this does not if
we do not get three riders in five
minutes then cancel the ride and then
you'll go back and message all the
riders and say sorry we cancelled your
ride if you'd like to reschedule you
know do X Y or Z with the goe in next
example would that store all the state
for all the drivers and all the riders
and the single kind of function state
object or that interface with a external
database every absolutely everything is
flink state there is no external
database here the way that we did this
is we essentially broke the map up into
cells and we have one instance per cell
right so within each function now we can
keep track in flink States who is in
what cell and we have some ways of then
also messaging you know nearby cells if
there's no drivers in my cell let's then
expand our search but the really key
thing I think for your question is no
database we are always using flink
States we are always going into our
state back end which is Flinx
abstraction for storing state locally
this can either be in memory or on local
desk but always local never an external
database and then we manage
fault-tolerance
using the apache flink runtime through a
process called snapshotting which is how
we do a synchronous distributed
snapshots of the state of your
application this isn't how it works I'm
want to preface what I'm about to say
with this isn't what actually happens
under the hood but a way you can think
about it is if we stop the world we have
all these distribute components imagine
that we stop the world we stop doing
processing we don't do that just again
not what happens and we copied all your
local states to say s3 HDFS some
distributed resilient location something
highly available and then in the case of
failure we can always redownload that
state and then you start running again
as if nothing had ever happened looping
in from the previous talk which
presented that problem of visualizing
end-to-end flow how do you do like let's
say with this these examples there's
like 10 these functions have messaged
each other and you want to understand
overall like what happens in your
application how so that that's a problem
we're actively discussing tracing and
any sort of messaging type system is
tricky what we're thinking about and
this may or may not be what we end up
doing but the idea that we're talking
about internally is well you know we
already got this really great system for
managing states you know I can we can
store hundreds of terabytes of state
like that isn't an issue and so maybe
you add in an extra function that just
kind of is a tracing function and keeps
track of the paths the messages have
taken and then you can message that and
say where have you been and that gives
us a way of essentially building up a
stack trace right well and if I was just
doing a regular Java application I would
get that for free if someone threw a
runtime exception because we are doing
these distributed systems and it is a
more flat call stack we need to keep
track of that ourselves
and I guess that's a long way of saying
it's not there yet but it is very high
on our priority list and if you have
ideas I would we would greatly
appreciate it thank you great good talk
by the way thank you mom
for that I guess how do you tense
instances get spun down I think in the
first case where you mention RPC or in
the third case egress it kind of makes
sense that once those calls are made you
know yeah go down but in that kind of
middle State where things are going back
and forth with it so okay so this is a
little diagram of the interpreter right
so what happened what is actually
happening under the hood is you have
these different function types so in our
right sharing example there are four now
there might be a million entities across
the different instances of those but we
have four function types under the hood
for each dispatcher and there's going to
be one on each parallel operator so in
the example I showed you I'm running
this flink application with parallelism
ten that means there are ten instances
of my dispatcher like physical instances
inside each of those there are only ever
four allocations literally ever and
there is one allocation for each type so
I have one driver function like physical
Java object one passenger physical Java
object and so on so in practice we very
rarely ever have to do allocations at
runtime if you would like to have so
many function types that we actually
could not keep them all memory at once
we do some things with weak references
that let them fall out of memory and
we'll reload them when we need them but
in practice you're gonna grab an object
that's already there your state is not
stored in the instance itself when
you're using a persisted value that is
really just a view into Flinx State
backends which again could be in memory
could be on disk always local and so
even though I might have a million
ongoing rides
I'm only have ten instances of my ride
Java object on the heap and I don't
actually have to worry about spitting
them up and down when I say we load it
transparently what I really mean is we
set the proper key for the state
back-end
for the current ride in this case such
that when you access your persisted
value it is going to be reading the
states for that particular ride there's
no actual reading in and out of memory
happening that's actually what I was
interested in kind of elasticity of
scaling up the scales yeah so again it's
a it's all the flink runtime we made I
believe one tiny runtime change and
flink to get this to work it's from a
practical point of view it's a library
in practice we want this to be a more
mature first-class API so we want this
to be on the same level as sequel and
data stream as far as where it sits on
the stack not like CP which is truly a
library you add on top but yeah so
scaling elasticity all of those things
are based on what Flint can provide so
we can make it distributed we can sort
our state backends we can make it fault
tolerance as far as allocations go again
we make a static number of allocations
on startup that is based solely on your
Flint configuration so again I'm running
that example I showed you parallelism 10
there are four function types that means
that there were literally 40 allocations
spread across 10 machines that's it
there will never be more allocations
[Music]